let me just read you this headline and
you tell me what it sounds like
JK Rowling's giant bush is causing
traffic mayhem in Edinburgh beloved
children's author JK Rowling is trimming
her bush outside this is wreaking havoc
on the Twittersphere so I'm gonna find
out what our office mates think and by
asking him and tell him about it who is
this woman
thanks JK Rowling take a roll and check
around JK Rowling if you heard she was
outside trimming her Bush what would you
think that's pretty indecent do you
think it's in a lightning bolt JK
Rowling's giant Bush is causing traffic
mayhem in Edinburgh
I guess she JK obviously is about a tree
bush is it obvious her new book Bush is
causing traffic like people are rushing
to the stores to try to get the book
sounds like JK's got a wardrobe
malfunction I'm not even surprised
happens all the time
Bush gets in the way a lot what do you
think that's about
your only push JK Rowling causes Road
raids by trimming her bush I think
that's an overreaction yeah I wouldn't
get angry by it he's a click daily title
you think they're quick mate she's not
picking up the pieces of the bush she
cut off
it sounds like pubic hair but I'm
guessing that it's landscape sound like
she's running around in traffic for the
pair of scissors yeah and the bush I
mean isn't it something like that
happened in Harry Potter I'm assuming
this bushes attached to her house Harry
Potter and the Prisoner of the traffic
jam
JK Rowling causes four days of travel
chaos after installing temporary traffic
lights so she can have her lay Landy
Bush trimmed is it lay Landy yes that's
a very English bush actually it sounds
like a fancy kind of Bush she just
installed a light and a lot of people
are upset by it why'd she install the
light so that she could get her bush
trimmed what do you think about that
well I mean I think that's kind of
selfish it's a boring story made popular
by a gross use of words well I guess
what we learned here today is that
nobody is safe even in Europe from
having something about their private
life be turned into a clique beatty
title about just their privates JK
Rowling's landscaping takes this spell
Quidditch more like Quidditch Jake
bangle it looks like Rowling's should
have been more of a Potter